pick up your broomsticks and [ __ ] your
boom sticks because the new trailer for
the chilling Adventures of Sabrina part
2 is dropped and this one will of your
heart beating out of your chest now this
trailer is chock full of action and
sweet tidbits of the upcoming season so
let's not waste any time and get right
into it we opened with Sabrina and a gas
canister walking the halls of Baxter
high she pours out the gas and lights a
flame because she thinks school is
really lit it's a great opening shot for
the trailer as it speaks to one of the
big questions going on in part 2 will
Sabrina hold on to her mortal half now
that she's a full-blown witch or will
she put it torch to it and watch it all
burn but back to reality and Sabrina's
walking the halls of Baxter high and
with a look at Harvey kinkle we can be
sure that will they won't they get back
together storyline is coming in full
force and Sabrina's bringing out her
inner bad girl now that she's signed the
book of the beast dancing with boys
other than Harvey at shirtless warlock
parties enjoying a nice relaxing
bloodbath
and snapping people's necks oh then
there's a shot of what looks like a play
written by Faustus Blackwood from what I
can tell it reads The Passion of Lucifer
Morningstar Lucifer Morningstar being a
fancy way of saying Satan and is also
the main character in the television
show Lucifer and was first featured as a
character and Neil Gaiman's comic The
Sandman now here's where we get into
some juicy details as Sabrina examines
call marks on her back they've been
teasing werewolves and it seems like
Sabrina is about to get marked by one
Sabrina's got new spells up her sleeves
and I think she's gonna need them check
out all these bats not only am I
thinking werewolves for this season but
I'm betting on vampires too we get a
fast sequence of action including blood
boiling Ambrose showing his blowing
skills and what appears to be Nik coming
out of a spell and Sabrina's bath or at
least I hope that's what it is
either way Hilda's enjoying the view
Sabrina and Nik burn open a door at what
appears to be a Valentine's Day dance at
Baxter high I'd bet Sabrina invites Nik
and we get some juicy love triangle
drama between her Nick and Harvey then
Susie with a fresh buzz cut loads up a
giant frickin shotgun like she's
straight out of terminator come with me
if you want to live something is
bringing everyone together to fight as
in this shot Nick and Harvey can be seen
working together oh and Harvey's got his
brother killing gun with him
check out the blood splatter on the
painting here too here Sabrina about to
smooch a werewolf and here Sabrina
actually smooching Nick don't worry
she'll be getting hot and heavy with
Harvey - love triangle drama and
Sabrina's got new tricks as well
seems like teleportation here and in
this shot Blackwood mentions levitation
followed by a shot of Sabrina flying or
falling in the air and then there's an
image of Sabrina in popsicle form kind
of like what happens if you were to drop
into outer space without a suit we also
get a cool shot of Sabrina with some
possessed eyes before it cuts to a
bloody mess being cleaned up at Baxter
High and a couple of Mormon looking
warlocks being burned alive check out
all the others they look like their
captives cut to Ambrose who's looking in
really rough shape
Sabrina's performing some kind of a
spell on him and check out the gashes
I'm getting the feeling Ambrose has a
run-in with a werewolf now here's
another reason why I'm getting the heavy
vampire vibes this shot of prudence with
the double blades and Ambrose with a
crossbow with those weapons and all that
leather it seems way too similar to the
blade in underworld movies speaking of
blades looks like Zelda and Hilda have
some levitating knives to deal with but
check this out remember the shot of
Sabrina's snapping necks those dudes
have some very similar looking knives
just saying and then we get Sabrina on
our roof with a broomstick and with all
this talk of new powers and levitation
I'm sure that means we're gonna see
Sabrina fly finally we get Sabrina
entering a dining room - man saying you
have loved the power I have given you
which means that this dude more likely
than not is the Dark Lord Himself in
human form makes a lot of sense to hire
a real person as they've been hinting
that the Dark Lord's true intentions are
to take Sabrina as his bride and I don't
know about you but I draw the line at
romance between Sabrina and goat man so
that's it for the trailer of the Chilean
adventures of Sabrina Park - be sure to
LIKE and subscribe and if you haven't
checked out my video on what we know
about season 2 get on it we're just a
couple of weeks away from the premiere
witches and warlocks so make sure that
bell is on scene though right away when
my
season breakdown comes out and remember
daddy loves you very much